[Applause]
how you doing
i hope you're well so this week the
media finally discovered crime because
finally they found a criminal who fits
the bill as they ignore others who don't
and make no mistake this is a villain
and i credit the outrage even if most of
it is only to exploit a tragedy
cnn political reporter concludes that
white americans aren't doing enough to
fight racism
you know oftentimes it is
african-americans who talk about racism
it is really a white cultural problem
that white americans have to come to
terms with why is it that african
americans and brown and black people uh
more generally are seen as the other are
demonized uh so easily in a lot of our
politics you know we still talk about
white supremacy but it's also the ways
in which people talk about folks coming
across the border the demonization uh
that goes around uh
about those folks that somehow they
also are a threat uh to america we just
demonize so racism is a white cultural
problem and whites should come to terms
with it
how does she know that they haven't what
planet is she on and why do they only
get cnn and msnbc there
but she echoes what her peers say that
whites share the guilt for their races
worst actions as if individual choice
responsibility or mental illness don't
exist
only an overriding pigment that unites
us in complicity talk about a wide brush
meanwhile this dope
thinks those who embrace free speech do
so to appease racists
well garrett look at the way the right
tried to weaponize the idea that the
depart the dhs was going
to essentially try and attempt to to
monitor hateful rhetoric right they want
to make it seem as if it's some sort of
big brother and it's like
this is always what the right does to
appease the white supremacist movement
by saying hey free speech
don't touch speech
yes so if you're for free speech you're
helping out the kkk
that's a leap evil knievel couldn't make
really msnbc maybe it's time to chuck
todd
thank you
terrible pun
disgusted by myself
he's a turd
a turd with a head injury under a
hairpiece
i could go on forever but i won't then
there's this guy saying we need a new
war on terror the terrorists being of
course republicans
my guidance is that we have to treat it
as the terrorist threat that it is you
know we rallied on 9 11. there was no
question about what the country was
going to do we are facing the same
threat
we should label them the domestic
terrorist party
hmm
wow next they'll say republicans are
divisive so this raises an idiotic
question because it's raised by idiots
are you responsible for a person's crime
cause you share a pigment and hasn't it
been drilled into every white person's
head since they were kids not to do this
kind of generalizing especially when it
comes to race
this is what the democrats are riding on
and it's a unicycle with a flat tire but
let's follow the logic if you're
responsible for what bad whites do what
about what good whites do
when a white person does something great
should you applaud me
does
does elon musk's privatizing space
travel and building electric cars cancel
out me having the same pigment as a mass
shooter or me at a party dancing like
i'm in a body cast while gnawing on
carrot sticks
isn't that true white supremacy that by
virtue of race i played a role in
inventing air travel
well i actually did more than once in
college i took acid and then jumped off
the library roof into a dumpster full of
trash
but by this logic of identity politics i
own everything good and everything bad
which is nuts by claiming that all
whites are complicit in the act of a
white madman cnn backed doors into true
white supremacy if whites put a man on
the moon i guess that means i might as
well be buzz aldrin
and you're welcome for the tang
idiotic it's idiotic but let's play this
game should all the japanese share guilt
for pearl harbor
and should all japanese be credited with
the best toilets on earth
admit it
they're pretty good
very clean
should all germans answer for the
holocaust i say yes except for heidi
klum
but they also gave us the pretzel
should all blacks be credited for
inventing the best music ever i bet you
didn't even know they came up with polka
music
but they're also partly responsible for
the black eyed peas
yeah i know you see how stupid this
logic is msnbc and cnn choose the worst
from a group and ascribe it to the whole
but how would they feel if we judge them
by joy reid or jeffrey tubin
actually i do
all the time i'm a hypocrite
it's a part of their single variable
thinking they have no mental dashboard
as they fly through life storms no data
statistics probability experience they
only see life through one filter race
so what about me well in case you
haven't noticed i'm short
in new research on violent crime short
men were twice as likely to be convicted
of a violent crime as the tallest
now maybe
most guys are more likely to take a
swing at danny devito than dwayne
johnson
but then you find out that the real
variable predicting violent crime was iq
it's the dumb short guys to blame
so i'm off the hook for stealing that
big wheel
and it's not just within short people
that differences like iq occur it
happens in all groups in fact there are
bigger differences within one group than
there are between two groups it's why
you have an
einstein and a tom arnold
it's why you have thomas soul
and joy reid
there are bigger differences within race
than between races that's huge
and why because we're individuals we're
brilliant funny weird high iq but enough
about me
we're also depressed and crazy and
vulnerable and dangerous
okay enough about cat
but it's not between groups it's among
people individuals so do i owe an
explanation for short violent dumb asses
because i'm short hell no just as i
don't take credit for all the great work
little people do like acting as a shoe
tree in my closet
but if you favor group identity over the
individual you would but you don't
because we see the person only the left
in the media see groups the only herd
mentality on our end is walking away
from them and the only place the left
doesn't want division is in math class
look at cat look at tyrus and look at me
the most important thing to gain from
this show is that we are different
persons i don't see cat as a white chick
tyrus doesn't see me as a white male
well he doesn't see me at all depending
on how close or far i am to him
nor do i only see him as a giant who can
flick me into space with his pinky
i see him as maybe the smartest guy i've
ever met
i just hope kudlow wasn't watching i
told him the same thing in the steam
room
and i see cat as the funniest creature
on earth and she's not even trying to be
funny she's just being cat
so in short
white supremacy
identity politics
you media what we are doing right now on
the show is the answer we embrace the
person not the pigment so screw your
identity
it's an evil that helps no race it's
just about power as evil always is
welcome tonight's guests
her name's tafoya and if you're a damn
she'll destroy us former sportscaster
michelle tafoya
so many people tried to cancel him you'd
think his name was cnn plus the reuben
report host dave rubin
give her liberty or give her an e-cig
and a shot at tequila fox news
contributor cat tip
and popeye wants to know what he eats my
massive sidekick in the nwa world
television champion
so tyrus short people aren't more likely
to commit a violent crime going against
your theories okay first of all they
said they were it was just the smart
ones don't get caught that's exactly
right that's what it is you lead your
little ring of married tiny man
and then you
have this code of short valor where you
won't tell on each other
well played penguin you guys get away
with it
no you know
great monologue phenomenal monologue and
as as someone who grew up when something
bad happened on the news i'd cross my
fingers and be like please don't be a
brother please don't be a brother
because we all get blamed for it right
now when we get into this point of
equality it's
not me because i know what it's feel
like to be grouped yes but when someone
gets to go on tv and their play is to
group all white people together and say
they're all bad
you're no different right
than
earl on the porch you're like oh you all
need to go back to africa it's the same
thing it's just because when they say it
they're saying it from a place of
supposed wisdom it's not they're just
playing down and they're running the
race game it's just because it's coming
from a person of color they're supposed
to get a pass because they have
convinced white americans to be afraid
to say no that's wrong
yes you still have to be black but
you're
right that's okay and you need to you
need americans need to start doing it
you gotta white america has to stand up
for themselves no one in this building
owned slaves
that weren't like a sex slave or knew
you or something yeah
but like
they didn't they don't own plantations
they got to pay bills they got
we all have the same issues we all have
the same hurdles different every one of
us got a sob story as a tragic as a scar
somewhere has nothing to do with the
color of skin it's life and where we
live so they're doing this bunching
because that's the easiest way to get
attention and get ratings i mean there
was a lot of murders and they only focus
on one why because it might get an
argument and people will tune in right
and they need the right and that's the
tragedy of it greg to be totally clear i
just want to make sure that we all know
that no one in this building has a room
in their basement with several sex
slaves nope nope
i can't stress that enough there is
absolutely
no private lot in this building right
next to the mail room and that's m.a.l.e
oh you know what i'm thinking
i'm sorry we were doing so well i know i
know i know i was almost a serious
person you know you were the first you
were on our first show yes what did you
say so i have to call you out for being
because i doubted you you what did you
say in the first show well first off
before i tell you that i just want to
say on the off chance that i say
anything offensive here during the
gutfeld exclamation point program i just
want to say i'm doing today's show as a
black lesbian that's what i am
identifying as today but on the first
show the first gut-felled show i was
sitting in this chair and i said you
would be the number one king in late
night within one year and
greg thank you
i said no it's not possible
i doubted you i doubted you because you
were gay i and and i doubted and i
doubted you because you're short and
here we are
yes
i'm glad we can we can exact bigotry
against each other and still respect
each other i'll see you in the mail room
later yeah
you'll deal with me i'll be in the mask
but i'll be the short one
i don't even know if you have any
gentlemen please
i'm with child
[Applause]
i've told you i'm told you can get an
abortion if it's necessary
we're doing that story tomorrow oh okay
oh you foreshadowed us what's with the d
what we used to be all about individuals
now it's all about groups of course well
the best example that you showed there
was thomas soul and joy reid right
because it does not matter their skin
color does not matter he is probably the
most genius economist we have ever had
in american history and and she is an
idiot who works at a mental institution
yeah and
those people their skin color has
nothing to do with those facts and if
you look at them that's the beauty it's
what tyrus is saying if you look at them
and you go oh that is a black man he
must think this way or believe this
about economics and she is a black woman
and she must think this
you need a mirror because you are the
racist you know it's funny uh uh
michelle i look at this and i think
about myself in the early 2000s and
being accused of islamophobia
this is kind of a new version of
islamophobia and sometimes i think maybe
i might have been guilty like when i was
like you know because of
because of 9 11 yeah i was like
i was looking everywhere and i'm not you
know but so maybe i wouldn't i have to
actually i mean if i have to accuse
these people doing that i have to look
at myself and see it but it's kind of
the same thing in a way you're starting
with the man in the mirror and that is
laudable greg oh thank you
that's my my tip of the cap to michael
jackson um
so they do it based on gender as well
yeah remember when we had the war on
women
a while back with hillary clinton
telling us all we women were oppressed
and there was this war on women and i
and here i was working as a woman in
sports one of the very few and i was
like where is it i don't i don't see it
i just think that
people forget that we're individuals
which was what you were talking about
and if you say that someone's not an
individual and they're only part of a
group it's because you don't have
another argument yeah and it's because
and you don't give that person
agency over their own lives you're
saying
uh it's too bad you're a white hispanic
woman you'll never be a sportscaster
because they just you can't they said
that to me did they yes
i would have held your hand it's why i
train i i i i would have transitioned
into a
uh a short man of german jewish is that
a painful transition yes yes greg can i
just make it legendary sportscaster tell
the truth you're you're legendary i've
got to get you here i got it
michelle michelle mentioned michael
jackson he's proof of it because in what
other country could a young black boy
grow up to be an old white woman
terrible all right cat you are in a
group of one
yeah speak
yep yep
is it how do you get people to break out
of this idea of just group think for
first of all i just want to say you know
the first version of your monologue that
i read you said i was the funniest
person you knew
and i found today yes you did some
editing and decided to change person to
creature
i did notice that oh yeah
probably is more accurate yes
uh i think that
it's not good to view everything through
a predetermined lens no matter what that
lens is but these people obviously do it
with race uh but if it's anything
because if you already know what you
think before you look at something then
you're not thinking at all right you
can't you can't think critically and
that's never going to be a good thing so
i think that looking at
situations individually and people
individually is the only way that you're
actually going to be processing what
you're seeing
good point thanks not bad for a better
creature yeah yeah
there you go all right before we go a
quick reminder i'll be in salt lake city
which is in utah cat this saturday for
my book tour tom salute but also tyrus
will be there
plus we got some
we got some new fall dates in
connecticut and texas go to gutfeld.com
for ticket info
up next her singing was bizarre and now
she's the ex disinformation czar
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else